we are here with Andrei diakonescu a
co-founder of one United properties one
of our big sponsors here at Superbad
just classic Andre welcome to the show
tell us a bit about yourself as well as
this partnership between one United
properties and super purchase classic
well thanks for the invitation
um we love to be part of this of this
event we love to be part of the
phenomena of Chess in general
I've myself been passionate about Chess
from a very young age
unfortunately I didn't go
um
deep into it because I had other
priorities but now that you know we
establish the business and we've grown
and so on I if I've found enough time to
allocate the both playing and
um
providing by way of sponsorship
towards the sport you're also the vice
president of the Romanian Chess
Federation and you're talking about the
Young Generation how important it is for
the Young Generation to have these Role
Models come here in Bucharest like
dingley ran the world champion
players of this caliber well I think
I think an event like that and and the
presence of such important players uh
will give a big boost uh to uh an entire
Young Generation who is passionate about
Chess so I think uh that uh the fact
that we we are we are being involved in
this and we uh we have managed to
organize uh such uh an event at such a
level
um will will for sure
um feed our our Young Generation for the
next perhaps five to ten years and will
for sure uh see results in that period
and we see already results we have
Bogdan Daniel that here we have Richie
report when do you think we're going to
see the next big super Talent come from
Romanian chess I think I think uh I hope
actually that the next opportunity is
already born it's just we haven't seen
him yet obviously this player that you
mentioned that are extremely good yeah
they play at the top level but I truly
hope that the effort that we are doing
now especially with the chess in schools
and so on with more than 20 000 uh
players that are certified uh will will
bring the big mass
and will will have enough risk will
provide enough enough resource for many
top level players in the years to come
I'm feeling the Strategic thinking
behind all this plan uh great thank you
very much for joining us thank you for
all the support and we'll let you go
enjoy the games now thank you very much
as well